I'm Alice Alice Alice Alice please stop  avoiding me Alice look at me for a  second  [Music]  Alice is nearly separated loser okay no  I'm not you haven't I've got this things  know about you and it's super impressive  you seem to be handling everything  really well Alice doesn't know what she  wants  you got to check yourself everything's  gonna be okay when were you gonna tell  me that three strangers were living in  yes I just always act out on my birthday  it's like my own personal New Year's Eve  though I just feel like just really back  to normal  did you wash these I did but only  because I was doing a load and I've been  up since my thirty forty right like  ballpark I am not involved with her okay  I just love a lot of things about her  like her face and personality  [Applause]  maybe it's fate that they met you  [Music]  you